okay if you want to get a sense of how
long this election fraud stuff is going
to be going on
um donald trump
uh just sent a letter to the georgia
secretary of state brad raffensberger
demanding that he be declared the winner
of georgia trump demanding that trump be
declared the winner of georgia don't
check your calendar this isn't a repeat
it really is mid-september of 2021 it's
not november of 2020 it's not december
of uh 2020. um it's uh it's almost
october of 2021
and uh donald trump is demanding that he
be given the state of georgia in the
november of 2020 election donald trump
sent this letter on friday i fully
expected when i saw this headline i
thought this must be from months ago it
must have just resurfaced like it can't
be from now
but indeed it is uh the letter is dated
september 17 2021. uh the letter says
dear secretary raffensberger
large-scale voter fraud cap random
capitalization i still don't understand
that his followers do it too large-scale
voter fraud continues to be reported in
georgia
enclosed is a report of 43 000 absentee
ballot votes counted now the count
counted is capitalized guys it the
counting is so important that he's put a
capital c on it in the middle of a
sentence absentee ballots of ballot
votes counted in dekalb county that
violated the chain of custody rules
making them invalid
i would respectfully request that your
department check this and if true along
with many other claims of voter fraud
and voter irregularities start the
process of decertifying the election or
whatever the collect correct legal
remedy is and announce the true winner
he's saying announce me as the winner of
georgia it's october
as stated to you previously the number
of false and or irregular votes is far
greater than needed to change the
georgia election result people do not
understand why you and governor brian
kemp adamantly refused to acknowledge
the now proven facts and fight so hard
that the election truth not be told you
and governor kemp are doing a tremendous
disservice to the great state
capitalized of georgia and to our
capital and nation
which is systematically being destroyed
by an ill illegitimate president and his
administration the truth must be allowed
to come out thank you for your attention
to this matter
their argument is that because some
forms were dated a few hours late
i'm interpreting what is being said here
okay
some forms were dated a few hours late
they want
every result from all of those
ballot boxes thrown out and not counted
they want to disenfranchise tens of
thousands of voters
because of some messed up paperwork with
some of these ballots now the law that
they cite is this emergency declaration
which has rules for ballot drop boxes
it doesn't say
if any rule is violated you throw the
all the ballots in the box into the
trash it doesn't actually say that it
doesn't say throw the votes out and
don't count them so
all of this is being signal boosted by
articles being written that say
because it appears that maybe some
ballots had a uh
were a few hours late in being certified
you need to just throw out all the
ballots from those ballot boxes there's
nothing in the law that suggests that
that should be happening so at this
point is this a mental health issue
is this trolling
is it grifting it was just this letter
was released just before the saturday
rally in support of the trump rioters
maybe it was an indirect way to try to
rile people up remember donald trump
remember when he just asked for 11 000
votes to be found for him i need 11 000
votes give me a break
this guy seems willing to do anything
but again the issue is the burden of
proof
he says he has the evidence but he wants
brad raffensberger to prove that his
allegations are true
what this may actually be
is an attempt to preempt
what increasingly seems like is going to
be an investigation
into trump's attempts to overturn the
georgia results this is an article from
friday the same day as this letter came
out
georgia criminal probe into trump's
attempt to overturn 2020 election
quietly moves forward
quietly moves forward so this may be
trump trying to argue look
i wasn't trying to break the law when i
asked for 11 000 votes what i meant is
what i said in this letter which is you
should investigate this and you should
investigate that it's kind of like that
weasley mafioso type speak that we've
become accustomed to from donald trump
but a delusional letter i was convinced
this letter must be six months old no
it's from friday and we will continue to
follow it
one of our sponsors is blue blocks blue
light glasses i've sometimes had issues
falling asleep at night eventually
realize some of it might be coming from
the blue light emitted by my phone and
computer screens peer reviewed studies
show blue light can suppress the hormone
melatonin which can make it hard to fall
asleep because your sleep rhythms are
disturbed i've seen a lot of improvement
since i started using blue light glasses
from blue blocks most companies make
blue light glasses in a mass-produced
way with no quality standards but blue
blocks glasses are made in actual optics
labs in their australian headquarters
they have over 40 modern frames you can
choose from they have a prescription
version non-prescription even reading
glasses and for every pair of glasses
blue block cells they give a pair of
reading glasses to someone in need
you'll get 20 off when you go to blue
blocks dot com slash pacman the link is
right underneath the video and there's
also free shipping worldwide on orders
over 115 dollars